♪ ♪ ♪
- Une ambiance à l'américaine...
♪  ♪ ♪
pour accueillir en superhéros
le président candidat.
♪ ♪ ♪
- - 100 % Macron.
Vive Macron!
- Merci d'être venus
des quatre coins du pays!- Venur
en boucle des slogans.
- (foule): Macron président!
Macron président!
- Emmanuel Macron leur a d'abord
défilé ce qu'il a accompli ces
cinq dernières années, comme il
dit, une cavalcade de progrès.
- Et l'inégalité en matière
de santé...
- Et il a enenenté ses priorités
s'il devait rester à l'Élysée.
- L'égalité femme-homme
sera la grande cause
du quinquennat qui s'ouvre.
(acctititions)
- Emmanuel Macron devance ses
adversaires dans les sondages,
en parti grâce à son action
en tant que chef d'État au coeur
a a a diplomatie internationale
pour tenter d'arrêter
la guerre en Ukraine.
EMMANUEL MACRON, candidat
élections président. françaises,
je le disais, bombardent
à quelques heures de Paris.
D'autres voudraient
nous ramener en France,
des années en arrière.
- Une flèche décochée
vers l'extrême-droite, dont
il dénonce la banalisation,
et en particulier vers Marine
Le Pen, qui se présente comme
la présidente du quotidien
et du pouvoir d'achat,
l'une des grandes préoccupations
des Français. Emmanuel Macron
promet d'en faire encore plus
pour aider les ménages
et les travailleurs.
- J'assume, oui, de viser
l'objectif du plein emploi.
- Comme en réponse à la
candidate du Rassemblement
national, Marine Le Pen,
qui pourrait causer la surprise
au deuxième tour, à en croire
les récents sondages
sur l'éventualité d'un duel
avec le président sortant.
- Je pense que c'est un vrai
danger. Je pense qu'il a eu
raison aujourd'hui de dire
que rien n'est gagné, rien
n'est fait. Il faut pas avoir
d'arrogance par rapport
au résultat de ces élections.
- Emmanuel Macron, qui refuse
tout débat avant le premier tour
de scrutin, a tardé à défendre
sa candidature. Ce premier
et seul grand rassemblement
pour convaincre les Français
n'arrive-t-il pas trop tard?
- Non, au contraire, parce qu'on
entre dans le "money time".
Justement, là, on est à...
on est à une semaine du premier
tour, un peu plus d'une semaine.
Voilà, il faut justement tout
donner. Là, ça a redonné un gain
d'énergie à tout le monde p
la dernière semaine de campagne.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Emmanuel Macron veut que les
Français soient derrière lui,
notamment ceux de la gauche,
qu'il courtise avec des mesures,
les voir bâtir, les voir lutter
contre le danger extrémiste
et contre le repli sur soi.Un a,
alors qu'il est en léger recul
dans les sondages.
Ici Anyck Béraud,
Radio-Canada, Paris